when you go back to your house tonight
before you sleep check your bed and
check the furniture in your bedroom see
if it's properly placed make sure that
the Wardrobe will not fall on you
when earthquake hits you tonight
disaster reduction is not necessary a
very attractive issue
it's human nature that you don't want to
see those
we cannot prepare for everything but if
we are better prepared at least we can
have quick recovery in Japan we have
something called the real time
earthquake early warning system there is
a time difference between the primary
wave and the secondary wave of a major
earthquake usually the disaster comes
from the secondary way so using the time
difference we can earn 5 to 10 seconds
maybe 60 seconds before the main shake
comes in the case of the March 11
earthquake we in Japan have the
Shinkansen bullet trains they were
running at the speed of 270 km/h but
using this system they put on the
emergency brakes speed it down to about
100 kilometers so when the main shake
came no derailment
so no injuries no fatalities but
unfortunately approximately 20,000
people were trapped the prediction was
for a magnitude eight point two or eight
point three perspec but the real
earthquake was banked in 9 which is far
stronger
it really emphasizes that we have to be
better prepared but to do this you need
proper investment we need international
concerted action to propagate the idea
that zester's can be reduced